blog ma numero 21
oggi sono contento perché faremo una
cosa particolare insieme alla mia
famiglia che facciamo di tanto in tanto
che sono le cacce al tesoro è partita
questa tradizione una sera che tipo
ciano iav amo e mi ha guardato lo ha
deciso tipo di creare all'interno di
casa di una caccia al tesoro ed è stata
forse una delle cose più divertenti che
abbiamo mai fatto e quindi da quel
giorno in poi abbiamo continuato questa
tradizione
una volta ogni due mesi tre mesi e oggi
mio fratello insieme a due sue amiche
hanno deciso di mettere in piedi la
caccia al tesoro più di sempre o
almeno questo è quello che dicono a
rocca priora per chi non la conoscesse
guardatevi tipo il blog mas è uno dei
blog uno scatto e ha deciso di fare una
caccia al tesoro horror
io faccio questa cosa non so perché mi
faccio così male ma inizia a piangere mi
guardo le persone che dicono loro
genitori che stanno per diventare nonni
ma tipo mi guardo le ore di questa roba
e piango
non so perché lo sto facendo vi prego
ditemi che non sono l'unico che fa
questo mi fa troppo piangere vedere
queste cose mi ricorda di essere vivo e
di avere delle emozioni ok ok ho perso
tutto aggiornato al computer devo
muovermi perché stiamo andando
ma adesso mi devo mettere come al solito
la roba per questo freddo invernale
terribile che ci sarà stanotte anche
perché scusatevi poggia sul letto fino
sto gestendo nel frattempo bar diabolik
ragazzi siamo pronti per questa sfida
ci hanno dato un'altra location dobbiamo
arrivare in quest'altra location ed ho
preso una super torcia tecnica chiudere
il flusso e deflusso a una domanda ma
quando chiude il flusso che serve
qualcosa lo uccisero de vito deve
indicare il mostro sicuro tutti per
questa avventura di morì a casa la linea
lungo leopizzi aver preso un po troppo
seriamente
adesso smetterà di parlare è una notte
di luna piena
vi siete persi pagate da tanto siete
infreddoliti e affamati tutto non avete
scorto nulla e non sapete dove passare
la notte quando un tratto giù in fondo
scorgete della luce forse una casa
dettaglio forse una casa ragazzi ma in
fondo non vedete una luce qui ci dice
atto primo
esci fuori un secondo al terzo non
guardare piero sono sceso dal pericolo
atto primo la tenuta dei miller al terzo
non guardare già al terzo decreto palo
ci siamo già bloccati che luci c'era da
vedere tutto prospettarci in faccia io
vi giuro
ecco chi ce l'ha più lungo la la
facciamo
abbiamo trovato la chiave ma non
funziona abbiamo dato la chiave ma ce la
diamo impazza
non ci credo non ci credo forse sta così
[Musica]
chiudiamo troviamo il marchio inseriamo
un marchio macchina ecco ecco ecco a
cosa ti ha già dato qualcosa si sente
male e viene più di mattina la cosa che
mi emoziona ma per favore ragazzi ma le
facciamo qui facciamo in tanti sono la
merito del nostro nome riporta avanti i
tamil errani miller miller procura vuol
dire che hai fatto veramente un pezzo
raro abbiamo scritto la risposta con sul
vetro per parlare con qualcuno che che
forse non è vasto mondo ragazzi se
seguiamo notti creiamo una sera
ci siamo ci siamo persi stiamo cercando
un aiuto in realtà la nostra macchina
capisco siamo a corto di benzina da un
po che abbiamo perso una strada mi
dispiace che sia per giunti nella tenuta
dei mille proprio in questo momento così
angusto per noi come mai se posso pero
purtroppo tutta la nostra famiglia è
morta siamo rimasti gli ultimi tre mille
dio
il capostipite ormai già con mille io
sorella elena e la piccola strahinja e
riposa mi sembra che il male si sia
impossessato e la nostra consorella cosa
vuoi che la us media as media e possa
sempre si sveglia solo con la luce il
sanzione puoi offrire qualcosa insieme
altri regimi accoglienti
non solo nero non sono bianco nella mia
mia maglia tutta nera
cos'è certo all'altro corona allora è
nato in danimarca di patate laddove la
più grande di coppa sarà lì al centro se
dietro la porta non lo voglio sapere
dietro l'altra catania morto e guardo il
mondo da un oblò che cosa ma che se le
mangiate non si può nominare casa perché
noi segnalati geloso ma se no la media è
visto
c'è un ultimo per correre nel caso mi fa
arrabbiare ma questo non avete ragione
veramente la bilancia no io non so come
totem popolato è chiamata la
coraggiosissima è se news.it non ti
scotti il seno news i non ti scuola di
via così sì il volo vicino
hanno tutti ho molta paura
spero di riuscire ad arrivare a domani
40 di troppo per a 40 minuti avanti
l'orologio c'è qualcosa una lucertola
milan parla con jacob chiedi di us melia
sapere cosa è successo a vostra sorella
il problema che da quando sono iniziati
a morire tutti i mille si sente strana è
come se ci vedesse chiusi qui è l'unico
modo devo dire c'è un generatore nella
falegnameria e l'unico modo per
accendere le luci è un generatore
allevatori è questo qui eccolo quindi no
io non lo dico io ma doveva uscire e poi
un tiro io che sto piccola non ero più
ci vai la v vai vai tu non puoi di pino
vedrà domani il secchio
guarda nella casetta della roulotte che
cos'è spirito al con occhio
ok lasciava a bruciare fuoco
[Musica]
per ora
credo che sbaglia va dalle strade
sveglia a fare portare un lampone
ragazzi allora prendiamo questo premesso
questo questo e questo ep ciccio così si
quello là e è proprio quello eccola lì
c'è un'altra presa da prendere dietro
bravi bravissimi dice prova della
fiducia a smell e vi sta aspettando
vicino all'orto averli a smell
infastidita dalla vostra presenza prova
la vostra fiducia che uno venga avanti
vai riccò forse tu sei quello che merita
più la fiducia di us media è un break di
ben dark svegli e ti acceca
no dobbiamo comandare il ricoh quarti
quando tra i pali perciò il punto
d'arrivo
secondo secondo me quello che ci passa
quindi allora mettiti ora a quattro
zampe
devi stare molto più basso rispetto a
così come una macchina bravo
ora tutto dritto tutto detto così tutto
dritto rimani basso dritto raddrizzati
gira verso destra fa perno con le
braccia bravissimo ragazzi controllatelo
voi da lì nicchia e non metterebbe
indietro ma il busto in avanti devi
rotolare su se stesso in senso anti
orario perfetto bravissimo enrico alza
leggermente il busto ora puoi andare
indietro con un pochino dove stare
la mano sinistra dietro la testa bravo
perfetto
prova dell'intelletto
la sera a terra abbiamo questa prova di
inter dell'intelletto è una la serra
andiamo ad andare forse nella sera a
trovare una pianta che faccio a sé
stante monica e per facciamo qui al
freddo
anna si c'è il biglietto li michael
allora aiutami a crescere il filo di
botticino
ricordo che dice questo è oltre i
confini della tenuta tra la tomba nyanza
è quella di james tra le due tombe
giusto si fregia
lei sì sì sì ci sono bambini
ok
tira pure però perfetto
ottimo mi chiamo donare la vita non solo
[Musica]
che dice
trovate la tomba la tomba del cesar che
ne preservi qualcosa di strano
victor sono victor capostipite dei mille
dio il sempreverde victor devo dirvi la
verità
qual è siete stati ingannati da chirone
miller a quelle cose lì dove sei ascoli
non fidatevi di elena elena ragazzi si
spegnerà la luce presto leggete la best
è scappata ha fame pensati in fretta
fuggite da colacone lì a sinistra e
ragazzi
[Musica]
[Risate]
è un missione in modi 800 l'ha mangiata
sto mangiando la bestia saziata è stata
uccisa ecco sta cercando di entrare ma
non può entrare se non può entrare non
si è stanziato la linea quando la bestia
ragazzi e ragazze è scappata pensate in
fretta fuggite dai quest'anno di fatti
di sangue
salve sta succedendo qualcosa in casa
andate alla finestra ordinati cautamente
prima dai mille morirai manchi solo tu e
lo è prossima rinchiuderà dentro sorella
[Musica]
noi siamo di gloucester dicono i
dominatori del mondo
e tu morirai questa notte insieme ai
tuoi ospiti beretta ha perso fuga dalla
villa tocca il segreto dei cloud resto
il comignolo saluta se la scala il no
leggilo to presto presto
poi c'è un singolo così eccolo 28
non lo so ne abbiamo buttati nel sacco
esce fuori qualcosa
ben diversa la chiave per chiostro
simpatico ragazzi questa cosa qui
la macchina
cioè se sta messo così quella è la
macchina
[Musica]
i ragazzi abbiamo perché ci torno a casa
qualcosa
questo e qualcosa
non potevano sapere che c'è a essere
macchina
se noi stiamo parcheggiate qua sopra
ecco perché sono stati così attente dove
farci parcheggiare quindi bisogna
tornare fuori prendere la macchina
investirli mentre abbiamo una macchina
mentre gli altri prendono quindi non c'è
sempre
siamo sotto la veste di indossano
femminili si sta aprendo il portone di
uccello asmel i poteri di asm irina il
potere di asm e gli stati con noi e sas
vedenti se c'è qualcuno li prendo io
faccio fuori si può non fare fuori del
guardiano che è simpatico
anzi dell'america ragazzi gianmarco ci
ha preso il via già marco ho detto vieni
a giocare con noi no un compleanno
sansone ragazzi bellissimo bellissimo
molto bella nonostante ragazzino andavo
a mangiare a casa emanuela ci vediamo
domani sempre a 14 con un altro blog
basse grazie ancora ragazzi allora oggi
è il giorno della caccia al tesoro e
ovviamente mi sono portato gianmarco
come giocatore loro non sanno della sua
presenza quindi quel momento sarà epico
penso li facciamo sotto nelle vesti
della bestia
allora adesso abbiamo un problema perché
sono le cure e sono le cinque e ancora
non abbiamo preparato niente
loro arrivano loro arriveranno verso le
vediamo chi la paga solo proponeva di
scrivere sul legno per fare una cosa
seria
bellissimo sarà fatto è composta da tre
atti alto primo arrivava la il mass
media e cattiva atto ii a sbaglia si è
svegliata e crea bando fino ad arrivare
al asbury e bona noi siamo i cattivi
devono fujian a villa pensando
all'ultimo tv ma questa mi hai
raccontato una storiella fantastica
alla fine adesso possiamo fare i
biglietti